einer war in der tür und da waren die
knie alle blut und die andere man fahre
alle hier alle blut und trocken bei
aller blut am vierten oktober werden
zwei männer aus nordrhein westfalen in
dresden mit einem messer attackiert ein
mann stirbt der andere überlebt schwer
verletzt
jetzt wird klar die tat war offenbar ein
terroranschlag die polizei fasste den
mutmaßlichen killer einen 20 jahre alten
isis anhänger dna spuren am tatort
brachten die ermittler auf die spur
bei den mutmaßlichen mörder soll es sich
laut bild informationen um abdullah
handeln
unfassbar der syrer aber nur fünf tage
zuvor aus der haft entlassen worden ein
gericht hatte ihn 2018 wegen anleitung
zur begehung einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden straftat verurteilt
im aktuellen fall hat nun die
bundesanwaltschaft die ermittlungen
übernommen es handelt sich also in den
augen der ermittler um einen
terroranschlag mit radikalislamistischem
hintergrund
die ermittler haben ganz lange keine
spur gehabt zum täter ein messer wurde
keine dna-spur gefunden und dann durch
akribische auswertung der bekleidung des
opfers da hat man noch eine dna-spur
gefunden und da hat man da an einen
treffer in der polizeidatenbank gehabt
gefunden und er führte dann zu diesen
terroristen sofort ist ein
sondereinsatzkommando zu seiner
asylunterkunft gefahren da hat man ihn
aber nicht angetroffen aber intervention
kräfte die in der dresdner innenstadt
unterwegs waren
weil die stadt hat man hat die polizei
jetzt hier in dresden eine penibel
bewacht weil man hatte ja immer angst
dass der täter noch einmal zuschlägt die
konnten ihn dann überwältigen und
verhaften
ja so spät haben die behörden das erst
gemerkt warum ist man nicht viel früher
von einem terroristischen möglichen
terroristischen hintergrund ausgegangen
die spurenlage war relativ schwierig
gewesen das motiv ist unklar
der täter hatte von hinten angegriffen
zwei männer in einer dunklen gasse in
dresden hatte nichts geraubtes hätte
auch ein verrückter gewesen sein können
das hätte aber auch jemand im
drogenrausch zugestochen haben
das war am anfang an klar gewesen jedoch
muss man sagen hätte man den täter der
erst unmittelbar zuvor aus der haft
entlassen worden ist
jaja es gefährder eingestuft ist penibel
bewacht
dann wäre es dazu nicht gekommen ja da
ist es angesprochen thomas er wurde fünf
tage vor dieser tat aus einer haft
entlassen warum war der täter überhaupt
noch in deutschland es ist relativ
schwierig selbst wenn man als gefährder
eingestuft ist der mann im konkreten
fall war es geht eher der stufe 3
eingestuft als brandgefährlich
nach meinen informationen hat ihm sogar
das landeskriminalamt in einer gefährde
analyse so eingestuft dass es möglich
ist dass er sogar noch mal eine straftat
verübt innerhalb deutschlands und man
hat ihn dennoch nicht rund um die uhr
bewacht offensichtlich ist das zwar
vielleicht alles korrekt dass man ihn
nicht 24 stunden überwachen kann
aber das ist halt quartal und du kannst
halt niemanden abschieben mit der aus
einem bürgerkriegsland kommt die syrien
da gibt es ein sogenanntes abschiebe
hemmnis und das wird ja immer wieder
diskutiert ob man das nicht wie in
anderen ländern ändern sollte guten
morgen herr naumann hätten sie damit
gerechnet hat sie das überrascht dass
das ganze nun als terror fall eingestuft
wird
na ja schon natürlich aber andererseits
ist es natürlich so dass er als
gefährder bekannt war dass man auch bis
zuletzt bis zu seiner freilassung aus
dem gefängnis im prinzip davon ausging
dass das einer ist der wahrscheinlich
neue straftaten verüben wird insofern
hätte es 5 4 für die
strafverfolgungsbehörden zumindest keine
überraschung sein sollten
und das ist genau das problem wir haben
in den letzten jahren sehr viele leute
gottseidank verhaftet verurteilt ins
gefängnis gesteckt aber sie häufig zu
sehr kurzen strafen verurteilt das
bedeutet dass jetzt sozusagen eine welle
von leuten kommt nicht nur in dresden
sondern überall in deutschland die jetzt
wieder aus der haft freigelassen werden
und in vielen fällen ist es eben nicht
so dass sie sich im gefängnis die
radikalisiert haben sondern ganz im
gegenteil in einigen fällen kann es
sogar sein dass sich ein gefängnis noch
weiter radikalisiert haben und
möglicherweise wieder einiges anders
ja hier schlug der täter fünf tage nach
seiner haftentlassung zu
hätte man ihn besser überwachen müssen
und hätte man das überhaupt gekonnt das
fordern immer viele und sagen alle
gefährder sollten eigentlich überwacht
sein 24 stunden am tag aber das ist ein
riesiger aufwand da so ist braucht
ungefähr 20 polizisten oder 20 beamten
um jemanden 24 stunden am tag zu
überwachen wenn man davon ausgeht dass
wir mehrere hundert gefährde abend dann
können sie sich vorstellen wie viel
aufwand das ist in diesem fall hätte es
tatsächlich eigentlich so sein müssen
wenn man tatsächlich zu dem schluss
gekommen ist dass dieser mann eine akute
gefahr für die öffentlichkeit darstellt
dass man ihn eigentlich gar nicht aus
dem gefängnis hätte entlassen sollen die
bewachung die dann kommt möglicherweise
ist dann quasi nur noch ein hilfsmittel
aber man hätte ihn eigentlich gar nicht
entlassen sollen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bet schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren